welcome everyone to today's webinar
centrifugal elutriation utility in the
flow cytometry laboratory my name is
Randy Lochner and I'm the strategic
marketing manager for centrifugation at
Beckman Coulter we're delighted to bring
you this educational seminar presented
by lab roots and sponsored by Beckman
Coulter life sciences Beckman Coulter is
a world leader in centrifugation and
flow cytometry and has long been an
innovator in particle characterization
laboratory automation and genomics
Beckman Coulter products are used at the
forefront of important areas of
investigation and discovery for more
information please visit Beckman Coulter
comm we have a few important
announcements before we begin this
webcast is designed to be interactive we
encourage you to ask questions during
the event you can submit questions by
typing them in the Q&A box which can be
found by clicking on the green Q&A
button in the lower left of the
presentation window we'll try to answer
as many questions as we can
you can enlarge the slide window by
clicking on the screen in the lower
right hand corner of the slide window if
you have any technical problems viewing
or hearing this presentation please
click on the support button on the top
right of your presentation window or
submit your problem to the Green Q&A
button in the lower left and now I'd
like to introduce today's speaker
Peter Lopez is currently a research
assistant professor in pathology at the
NYU School of Medicine and is the
director of the NYU LMC
flow cytometry facility he has published
over 30 scientific articles or book
chapters and serves on the Executive
Council of the International Society for
the Advancement of cytometry and the
Executive Board of the Association for
Biological resource facilities Peter's
career has been devoted to utilizing
flow cytometry to facilitate research in
biological sciences and his interest in
designing new applications has led to
his labs current research into utilizing
centra vehicle future
in the flow cytometry core facility
before we go to the presentation itself
we have a few poll questions that we'd
like to ask our audience please take a
few seconds to respond to the questions
on your screen now the first question is
simply do you operate flow cytometer so
we have a majority of the audience that
does have experience with full cytometry
not surprising giving the topic the next
question is do you have experience with
centrifugal elutriation or what some may
know as counter flow centrifugation
also a somewhat expected result and
we're very happy to be able to introduce
you to the concept final question before
we turn it over to dr. Lopez do you work
in a core facility environment
thank you very much for taking the time
to answer these poll questions and
please if you do find the webinar
content interesting share the
information with your colleagues at this
point I'd like to turn over the virtual
podium to Professor Peter Lopez Peter
it's all yours thank you thank you Andy
and thank you all for joining in on our
webinar today and in particular I'd like
to thank second-quarter for sponsoring
it and for their support in the work
that's going on in our lab related to
creation so I'd like to start by
actually reviewing the poll looks like
we've got a good number of folks who are
using flow cytometry about 60% it looks
like I think everyone has probably seen
these I think they get pushed out to the
audience we have about a quarter of the
people on the Carll have used in the
Creator which is great anticipating some
interesting questions from those folks
and and we have about a third of the
folks on the call who are working in a
core shared resource facility kind of
environment the goal of this
presentation in a way is to potentially
draw all three of these groups together
with with with the utility of creation
in a core cytometry course specifically
so let me start with my first slide so
centrifugal elutriation as Randy
mentioned is also known as counter flow
centralization it's a biophysical cell
separation technique in which the size
and I'm sorry one second guys I
okay god I had something on my screen it
says so this is Mises segmentation
density differences in living cells as a
means of purification and for isolating
cellular subpopulations the benefits are
there there are a number of benefits and
benefits in separation compared to other
techniques you can peel ply cells
without the need for labeling so this is
kind of powerful in that you don't have
to process the cells in any way before
before separating yourself you can
provide large numbers of cells and it's
been reported on in some situations
where you can process billions of cells
and there are other techniques that
we'll talk about where this is possible
and it's certainly a little challenging
in the flow cytometry cell sorting
environment to do this type of these
type of numbers and lastly one benefit
is that this purification is done with
minimal stress only assaults the
priority stress is the g-force of this
entropy and we'll talk a little bit
about that about what the g-forces are
that are involved and as we go further
in a punk
so basically centrifugal elutriation
there are two opposing forces that come
into play in a specialized centrifuge
rotor and chamber there's the centrifuge
force that's generated by this awareness
of the standard kind of g-force that we
need for powering cells in other
standard centripetal applications the
differentiator here is a indy apparatus
is the ability to counter flow fluid in
the opposite direction of the sequence
so it's the centripetal direction and
these two forces are kind of can reach
an equilibrium in cells will find their
little niche where they want to sit and
it's the
on the segmentation velocity of the
cells so to illustrate this we have this
strong and you can see our what were
illustrating here is the the is the
actual chamber of the creator and
there's the the vertical line that
you're that you're seeing there is the
is is the I can illustrate this I think
which is right here this is the area
that is the elutriation boundary and
during loading the cells have a tendency
to want to be moved out in the direction
of the centripetal force which would
move things in this direction but at the
same time you can see illustrated a
counter flow the small the small path
here and that eventually will flow in
the opposite direction and this is done
wireless for then allow the secretary
jiz swinging so that's kind of an
interesting change to what people
typically expect in a centrifuge
typically just put cells into the
centrifuge and you spin them and you
take map but in this case you're loading
cells into the centrifuge as well as
removing them kind of as it's spinning
and that's kind of the one of the one of
the special aspects of the significantly
creative so this technology has been
around at least in its theoretical
applications since the beginning of the
1900s and I illustrate the Lindberg here
with the H at the end of the name in
parentheses this is kind of a funny
little story because there are a couple
of references that
Lindburgh with a g' and not the age from
a 1932 reference and in finding this
reference it turns out that this is in
fact Charles Lindbergh the pilot who in
1927 flew from New York City to Paris
and surprising to me and possibly some
of the audience know this story but
after after his transatlantic flight he
ended up working in a laboratory at
Rockefeller University in in New York
City working with Alexis Carrel and
tissue culture lab and it is in fact
Charles Lindbergh who devised the
original flow system which was useful
washing essentially in but in the
Washington step it was noting that back
in the day they were called corpuscles
blood corpuscle sperm cells like cells
were retained in the chamber and smaller
particles were removed and in between
that initial observation by Lindbergh
and there wasn't really that much
significant alteration done because
there the apparatus wasn't available so
between 1932 and 1973 roads and a whole
lot of the creative work being done
until that then instruments introduced
the first commercially available
centrifuge on the creator and later
requirements were made in particularly
these requirements were in the chamber
design we'll talk a little bit about
that but the center's into 1976 and
that's one that was is a popular chamber
this in our lab in particular so just to
show you the proof in the pudding here
this is the original wing article and
you can see it's signed by Charles
Lindbergh
showing his initial apparatus for doing
central elutriation so moving this to
the current system what we're looking at
here is
a diagram a Beckman we create a system
and this is this is what we're actually
using in our lab there are a number of
points on the system that we can rethink
outline first off we have a specialized
apparatus which is the the Aleut
creating chamber which is which is here
and then the this is sitting in a
Beckman subterfuge and we have the
ability to to put material into the
chamber while it's spinning as well as
pulling material out of the chamber so
so these things can happen in real time
while the system spinning typically for
a lute creator runs in most laboratories
the centrifuge is held at a constant
rate the constant spin rate and the
sample introduction rate which can be
varied but simply by changing the
pah-wraiths this will this will allow
you to push material through and to
actually selectively a little smaller or
larger salesmen from the system so this
is kind of the special special apparatus
that that's required to do this one
thing to note is everything related to
the buffer reservoir to pump the
pressure gauge the sample injection this
could all be done in a hood and this
could be catch there all this entire
system could become sterile actually
which is which is an interesting an
interesting point also you might notice
that the pump
is behind the sample the samples are
sample is injected in in this in this
apparatus right here
the pump is behind that which is a plus
because the cells are actually going
through pump the pump is a peristaltic
pump they're typically pretty gentle on
cells but the fact that the cells are
not going through that prompt at all is
clearly a benefit so this is the actual
setup in our laboratory and we can point
out a few of the components here the
first of all this is a this is a halter
on tk20 xpi centrifuge it's made it's a
refrigerated centrifuge it's kind of a
standard large format centrifuge the xpi
modification helps for the elutriation
by adding a strobe light which you can't
see but it sits underneath the amber
colored chamber and this allows
visualization during loading you can
actually see cell being introduced into
this chamber it's a stroke as a strobe
light so it's in it's in segments it's
synchronized with the with the spin rate
with the RPM rate and you can actually
watch the cell being loaded you can
watch the elutriation boundaries being
point of course this this works when
you're using large numbers of cells but
it's very helpful in establishing
loading conditions in addition so by the
way this this this is the rotor inside
the the centrifuge and this is really
where all the action happens
that's you can see wines coming into it
that's where the where cells and and and
the creation fluid of being introduced
and and then there's an other lines
where the cells are being removed
selectively in addition in this picture
you can see that we have a biosafety
herd that's set up and in that hood we
can be constellar and introduce
themselves in a sterile environment as
well as collecting sales in its neural
environment so this is both put this is
both for introduction as well as
collection of practice and finally we
can we should point out the the
peristaltic pump which is here and this
is a really key component to the system
it has to be calibrated accurately this
is going to be delivering the cells
initially into the chamber and then
subsequently running elutriation buffer
at different flow rates and we'll talk a
little bit more about how that how that
effectively removes populations but it's
a key component to this system just a
little bit more of a close-up this is
the this is the sample delivery area and
in this area the again in in in a hook
we have a we have a magnetic stirrer and
we put a little more into this this
apparatus the cells are being introduced
via this way a syringe loaded typically
ten anoles of material concentrations up
to ten 5758 are introduced at that point
and um
they actually end up at the in this
little chamber here and the goal there
is to eliminate any air in the system
just like for clothes I tell them I want
centripetal new traitors really need to
be free in their narrative that thing in
an older traitor so this helps to do
that in that the cells will drip into
that into that volume and from there
they are slowly introduced into the into
the system from the from the pressure
from the pressure head coming from the
peristaltic pump this this again
illustrates the the process of
introducing material into the into the
over to agent amber which is illustrated
at the in the upper the upper
illustrated but that would be the
loading phase of the of the elutriation
actually getting the cells into into the
chamber and this is done while it's
spinning the cells are loaded at a flow
rate that will that will not oppose the
centrifugal force significantly so it's
all the the majority of the force on the
south that's the standard the standard G
Porsche from the from the Secretariat
the centripetal force is minimal at this
point and you can see that by our little
diagram here and that is what allows you
to retain those cells in in the in the
chamber to get them loaded in the first
place and then with increasing flow
rates that this is after these cells
have been loaded with increasing flow
rate of the creation buffer we can start
to
differentiate between smaller and larger
particles and one of the kind of
baseline ideas here is that the smaller
cells will come out at with a lower
velocity of the of the fluid and the
larger cells will be retained and if you
increase the the the ml MLS per minute
of the other fluid you'll get the larger
cells will come out so they come out as
fractions and the image down here is is
a the actual scrolled image of what's
going on in the chamber and you can see
the the triangular-shaped chamber in
there and you can actually make out the
elutriation boundary which is right look
sorry which is right there at that point
so this is during the loading and then
by increasing the throughput of the
fluid the creation buffer we can push
out selected fractions from this mixture
so why are we why do we want to do this
in a closed atomic facility so that's
kind of gets back to the poll and we
took earlier I think we've had that a
third of the perks are operating in core
laboratories you know the the core
laboratory in a lot of that these exist
a lot of academic centers and and
they're really a repository for
knowledge and for the ability to have
expertise in a certain in a certain
field and the flow cytometry
core laboratories typically are doing
analytical work but a large portion of
their work is involved with self
purification and
we see alliteration I mean which is
obviously a purification technique as
something that would make a lot of sense
in a corn pirate you know this
technology is fairly mature it's it's
been around like I just as I plugged it
out you know since the well since this
is the first commercial instrument in
the 70s and more often than not
elutriation has been used for specific
experimental goals for a particular
application and and the the notion of a
corner laboratory can can broaden this
so that it that the alliteration is not
used just for one application it can use
through many applications so you know
having it in the core and specifically
for cytometry facility this is where the
expertise in configuring an instrument
like Anna Lou creator or a number of
applications and there are a lot of
applications that we'll talk about
briefly and you know flow cytometry
facility has to deal with cells because
of a self purification services that
they offer so it seems like a logical
place for something like Anna Lou and of
course one way of looking at the success
or identifying fractions or the
appropriate fractions of interest you
typically have to rely on a flow
cytometry to the analytical side of
things so having that nearby this made a
lot of sense to us and this is why we've
been trying to integrate this into our
core facility offerings so this is a
comparison you know there are many
techniques that can be used for for
purification and we have flow cytometry
by cell sorting which is the one that we
we like the most intelligible but there
are the techniques of course there's max
magnetic bead separation and the
comparison here with the
CCE kind of centripetal counterflow
nutation
purity wise probably pleasant how much
it will always be the winner for that
you know we in a flow cytometry cell
sorting experiment you should be able to
to obtain 99% purity that that's
certainly obtainable that's not it's not
always the case but but we should be
able to obtain that probably will not
get comparable purities with elutriation
videogamer you'll get relatively close
as well as magnetic beam separation the
one one really big differentiator here
with the elutriation is the number of
cells that can be processed ten to the
nine and to the pen type cell
populations can be processed that's
definitely something that it's difficult
to do in a fluorescent comic restoring
environment in a magnetic bead
environment it can be difficult to do
unless you're using multiple systems and
you know actually you can do it with
multiple cell sorters but since itself
sorter is anywhere from $200,000 us to
to half a million or so having multiple
units is it's not a luxury that many of
us have be doing things simultaneously
and another kind of benefit of the early
Creator is that you can take multiple
fractions off into the system now you
can pick up the six fractions on a
Beckman Coulter austria cell sorter for
instance and magnetic bead separation
typically it's it's just two fractions
but the illiterate or you can take many
fractions if that's what you want to do
will be illustrating some cases where
that
what we want to do in the noodle case
where we just want one fraction in
particular and just to get back to the
issue with cell sorting since we're
working since we work in a cell sorting
facility the issue there is that the
machine is in a way it's it's a serial
machine it's one cell after the other
and and they have to be passed through
some sort of a droplet generating system
now there are other types of cell
sorters that are coming down the pike
that may challenge some of these some of
this long-standing limitations but let's
just focus right now on the more
traditional cell sort in unit the
droplet size really is important
consideration because the cells have to
be you can't make the droplet has to
enclose the cell and it can't be very
close to the size of the cell that's the
three to four times the size of the cell
and this is this this is a concern
because that risk that all of the the
cell sorting droplet generation and
fluidics it's all defined by physics and
there's only so much you can do there's
only there's only so much you can do
before the cells start to complain but
if they've been squeezed into T kind of
a droplet or they've been pushed through
to high pressure basically it's an issue
of how many droplets can you make per
second and that's the best that you
could come you could ever do as far as
how how fast you could sort of if you
can make a hundred thousand cells per
second in a perfect world you could sort
of hundred thousand per second but that
doesn't even exist and there's a reason
for that
the reason for that is is that cell
delivery the cells entering into the
floatin whole area and are entering
those droplets randomly and in this
chart you can see that and this is
basically just looking at massan's
because the arrival times specific
statistics and plotting this out that
you can see as
you increase you increase the droplet
generation with a hundred hundred teller
which means a hundred thousand droplets
per second you you can increase the the
yield the number of cells that you're
getting out of the system but you're
still only at about well I mean you can
pick your you can pick your number where
you want to be but at a typical setting
of the hundred thousand I think people
are usually operating at about twenty
five thousand cells per second which
gives you about an eighty percent yield
so twenty percent of the material is
just not being processed because it's
arriving into the system randomly and a
cell sorter can note that and the
preference of courses for purity and if
multiple cells are coming through at the
same time they are not sorted there or
it's called or boarded they're not
looked at they looked at but they're not
sorted so this is where the cell loss
occurs and as you continue the Gloria to
continue to try to go faster and faster
you start to get less and less material
so it's the nation returns you're not
going to be able to sort fast now of
course you have a number of these
soldiers running at the same time well
that's that's better but as I said it's
hard to do that there are some
microfluidic approaches that are coming
down the pike that may they may make
this a little bit more of a competitor
but put throughput the cell sorter isn't
going to be the highest throughput of
course it's going to probably be the
highest purity so let's talk briefly
about some of the things that have
already been commonly performed using a
newly creator the probably the most
widely used application is cell cycle
synchronization and we can we'll talk
about the benefits there and and we've
actually started to do that so easiest
out
applications are things that can already
be moved into a core setting so this
stuff has been well worked out there are
main papers many cell types that have
been been looked at so this is kind of
you know a number of application that
you can that you could quickly move into
a core environment like I said having it
having a setup like this in a core
environment with with staff gaining
expertise in the system
you can really you know and it's the tea
would really benefit from from having
this as an offering process many cell
different types of cells and many
different scenarios
whereas in a lot of cases in the past I
I think the the elite raters have ended
up just working in one particular aspect
of their of their of their capability
and and then after the experiments done
the elite Reiter probably doesn't see a
lot more action also a Richmond of cell
subpopulations from a cell mixtures is
why they done monocyte purifications is
widely performed also so these are
existing applications that can easily be
plugged into into a core environment so
to say you some a couple of examples out
of our lab this is a cell cycle
synchronization using the elite Raider
and these are terrific cells and what we
can see here are the robot famously
starting population the the cells
directly at the at the incubator and for
those who are not familiar with looking
at the it's all sort of data this
fraction here represents g0 g1 cells
that are not cycling having replicated
their
their DNA we have cells in s-phase that
are better whoops that are within this
range here and then finally we have
cells that are ready to divide or
dividing d2 and n are sitting right here
so the goal of synchronization is to get
every all the cells into the same cell
cycle compartment and then things can be
tested with with with drugs or molecular
techniques whatever the the benefit of
cell cycle synchronization using
elutriation
is that this can be done without
treating the cells in any way
synchronizations done a number of ways
currently usually involving some type of
chemical treatment like blocking an s
page is in hydroxyurea or a meeting
block or serum foundation to keep cells
back in to zero and then and then
allowing them to move out into cell
cycle by adding serum there is one
technique that can be used that doesn't
require there's one typing other than a
weekly inequity used that doesn't
require treatment and that's a mitotic
shake mitotic shake off of adherence
elsewhere so adherent cells will will
borrow up when they're in mitosis and
the point of adhesion to the plastic
culture plate is minimizing and if you
sharply wrap that flask the mitotic
cells will float up so there is so that
so that is a competing technology of
course that only worked through hearing
cells whereas the you traitor can work
on quite well on non adherent cells as
well as in here as well as accurate
cells so we talked about the established
application using removing
subpopulations and it's there there are
just tons of cells that then have been
in cell types and so so fragmented
there's been a lot of work in it if you
go online and search on elutriation
I'll be or a particular cell type you
like you might find that it's been been
done a lot of work with liver and and
there are a lot of conditions that have
already been established so this is this
is showing a number of different cell
types in the liver that could be
isolated with showing the the speed as I
said the RPM is held constant and then
you can see the flow rate in MLS per
minute to elite rate these different
fractions SEC sinusoidal endothelial
cells the other cells are attic stellate
cells there's B C's ileal cells so these
are all established conditions in early
traders and I mean this already is
something that can be plugged into into
a core setting again here's some other
cell types it goes bar jacks
B cells note here that we see some of
the the D forces in the in the column
there it's a centrifugal force of
elutriation
so these forces these are typical we're
looking at we're looking at 600 700 up
to even maybe a doubt in G they were
take for some of these populations and
in most cases they seem to withstand
this quite nicely we'll talk a little
bit about the the the entire setup and
by the way the flow rates were so then
I'll permit it they're bracketed and in
the CH o cells you see 12 249 that those
are centered around the mean the flow
rate is really determined by the cell
diameter and and and
and we'll talk we'll talk about that
actually determining the settings in a
minute here we have an example from our
lab of co-culture ileal cells with
Tweetie 3 feeders and these it's bovine
you're at the ileal cell culture and we
can see a pretty effective removal of
three T threes in your helium using the
trio from the starting population in the
left frame so just until astray ssin
from from our from our own lab of what
can be done so just show you briefly the
the workflow on how we pursue this and
and and refine this technique the sample
needs to be mono dispersed so this is
another requirement that's very similar
to what you see in a forest automata we
have to have single cell suspensions
clumps and aggregates will actually
disrupt the illusionator and really is
critical with these samples amount of
dispersed so of course we can check
these under a microscope it's it's
really highly advised to do that to make
sure that you've got a very good single
cell that and then the step to
evaluating the cell size this is this is
critical because this the cell size of
the cells of interest okay you need to
you need to be able to to to look to
find out what that cell size is it's
really best to to actually measure that
and there's a number of ways to do to do
that and you can
in addition evaluate using flow
cytometry you can use that to kind of
hone in on the population of interest
once this is all done
step two actually helps you to set up
the central reach right now and I'll
show you a couple of points on that in a
few slides later but initially the first
run on an elite trader is typically a
trial run so this is this will be on a
fraction of the material just to get me
to make sure that the Aleut rater
settings are working there is a bit of
an art to this
so we need to make sure that everything
is is behaving properly so we collect
fractions at different buffer flow rates
and remember the buffer the the flow
through the buffer flow rate has the
effect of elude treating out larger
cells when when the flow rate is higher
and smaller cells annex slower and then
that part we evaluate those fractions
- and that's typically done using a flow
cytometry or you could go to a primary
cell size to see if we're getting the
target population and see how well we're
doing
if and usually more often than not in
our lab we find that that that first run
we witness it with a good cell size
measurement we're pretty much we're
pretty close to where we need to be
we kind of know approximately where the
fraction will will be in the multiple
practice and the multiple fractions are
there - just bracket around where the
ideal the ideal speed the ideal speed
but if further fine-tuning is needed
then we just bounce back up to step four
and we do another run we just dial in
some different settings and then finally
when we've optimized the system then we
can just move up to the actual
experiment with the actual material and
collect the desired target cell of
course with again evaluate on a close
encounter to make sure that this is this
is the right the right fraction of
course cell counting as well as cell
sizing you can attempt to do that in
this commodore it's kind of tough having
an automated system like a my cell is so
really handy for this work for you can
get your answer with a high degree
accuracy and the other thing that is
really difficult to do manually is to
get a feeling for the distribution of
sizes if there is a distribution and
that definitely handy if there's a lot
of cells in cell cycle and and and as
well as cells that are not cycling you
can see that you can see those those two
sizes and and and can work them there so
what you do with the information from
the cell sizing and from the cell
numbers is the
what elutriation chamber to use are very
differently trade containment that we
have in our lap the standard electorate
is on the left it's kind of hard to see
the chamber in that one but it's it's
kind of it starts here in this little
triangular setting there so that's the
that's where the chamber sits in that
unit and then the Sanderson chamber is a
modification and this is the one that
came out in the mid 70s to help with to
help resolve populations on a little bit
better there's some controversy out
there as to if it's how beneficial this
unit is we're using it primarily but in
our work and and I think a lot of folks
are using it there is some advantage
specific particularly if you're talking
about the blood cells the large
sanderson chamber allows you to just
just process more more material it's got
a bigger volume so you can see that that
area is larger there
and this shows this this table shows the
different chambers the standard chamber
which we have the Sanderson chamber
which we have we the large chamber is
actually one that we don't have in our
line that is very similar to standard
chamber and it's profile it's just
bigger and the large Sanderson chamber
is not listed here it's it's got
different parameters for operation and
this tells you a little bit about how to
get them to get the instruments set up
how to get that chamber set up but but
also how the how much material can be
loaded effectively into these chambers
of course all of this gets back to the
physics and the basis of elutriation is
Stokes law which describes sedimentation
velocity there here's all the
information there is a link that we've
provided on this webinar to the Beckman
culture manual for centrality a
where this is where actually I I grabbed
this information for those of you who
are interested in in the nitty-gritty
mathematics this just works this the
Stokes law applies to the sedimentation
velocity but that's not all you need
because ultimately what you want to do
is a little bit mathematical to Max
gymnastics to get to the final equation
which is down here
oops which is down here which equates
cell size to rpm which we keep constant
and and also factors in a given chamber
information all of this stuff is
available in the manual that these
parameters but this the sanderson
chamber but the bottom line is that
equation can either be utilized on a
nomogram where you would just pick your
cell size the RPM and then you can see
what the what the best the goal here is
to find out what the loading of speed is
is how is the the fluid flow rate and
and you can see that here or
alternatively what we've done in our lab
is we've just we've just put it into a
little spreadsheet so we can put these
numbers up whenever we need them
so one kind of newer approach that we're
taking in our lab is to use the
illusionator
to remove small debris from samples that
have been that can cause itself sort of
some problems the reason why we need to
do this as it's a in a plus in how if
you live people are often presented with
samples that are made from primary
tissue where there's a lot of enzymatic
digestion some sort of sample
preparation that results in a lot of
degree this is kind of common the
machine sees the debris
if you allow the machine to see the
debris which people will debate if
that's good to allow it or not the
machine needs to see their debris in
order to avoid them the debris there's a
threshold Incan doing solar where you
don't see the debris but if it doesn't
see that if the machine doesn't see the
debris can't decide that not to sort it
and you might you might retain a lot of
debris and the sort of sample and this
could have some implications and
genomics applications or other
downstream applications so many labs
will will allow the cell sorter to see
the debris so they can try to try to
avoid it the problem is that debris is
all over the place in some of these some
of these preparations so we saw this the
elite rage the center proliferation as a
potential here for cleaning up these
types of samples as a first step before
cell sorting and in our lab we've been
able to we've started to work on this
and basically what we're doing here is
we're leading the way this small debris
and retaining the cells in the end
elutriation chamber so as opposed to
other techniques where you use a certain
elutriation setup in order to allude out
a population adventurous like like a
like a g0 g1 population in this case
we're looting away the stuff we don't
want we're letting all of the debris and
everything go away and setting them the
Machine up so that we optimally retain
the cells of interest so basically we're
just weird if we have a cell that's 10
microns for instance we're a little way
things that are that are smaller than 6
microns grow sense and that gives us
good retention and the other nice factor
here besides you know what we've talked
about earlier and that you don't have to
label the cells you don't have to
process themselves and it's a general
procedure is that this sample cleanup
can be performed very rapidly and this
would be a pre-processing step before
going on a cell sorter so you get more
efficient cell sorting and and and so
forth one other potentially potential
use here is for loading for loading some
of the I'm sorry I got ahead of myself
this is just an example to maybe better
make the point of a sample that has some
this this is small material this is
debris we're pointing here this this red
labeled material these are the cells of
interest these are these are monocytes
in a tumor prep and in this case we're
looking to get the monocytes out this is
an illustration of a potential problem
this is not an alliteration result that
we're showing here at the moment but
basically the question is can can can
you get these these cells out which are
here what with minimizing the amount of
this small contamination from small
material that comes along so we see the
initiator as a good first step to
cleaning this up the the way we're doing
this is to just hone in on these on
these cases we've got a model system
that uses jerkhead cells we can do one
of two things with the dirt get cells if
we leave them in the refrigerator for a
couple of days we get dead cells and
debris that come that come with we just
keep them in NPVs width and that's a
nice that's a nice model for us and we
use that and here's an example of
removal of debris using using the tree
one other sorry about that
New York City Street Sounds one of the
one of the advantages also that we see
for this is for single-cell genomics for
folks who have who are now using some of
the fluid ion products like the c1 where
cells are loaded and the missing many
partitions them out into their
individual into individual reaction
vessels or reaction chambers the cells
are introduced here I mean that simply
puts cells in and then the machine
we went into this this area one of the
issues with the system is effective long
as it's efficient loading of the system
and we feel that we can we can help out
with that also by using the by using the
illuminator
so as a summary pointed out a couple of
things here that the early protection it
would create alliteration to be useful
going to a place at home robbery and
become one of the services of course the
county lab offers and that's a great
place for this technology to land
because the court facility has the
expertise and we see applications in
addition to the established applications
with synchronization of cells or
removing subpopulations for
heterogeneous mixture we see this
relation degree is another another
benefit that were that were utilized in
our lab and of course the benefits that
we pointed out earlier that it requires
most no labeling or treatment it's a
general procedure and we can purify my
numbers themselves so the in summary
that's that's where we're at right now
in my laboratory and and we're pursuing
this further so in conclusion I'd like
to acknowledge Michael Gregory who's the
lab manager at the NYU Langone Medical
Center for closed circulatory facility
who has done most of this work that had
been presented in addition the other
members of our lab Nicole Hansen Gloria
and Keith pars and had had had some some
input into this work so I'd like to
acknowledge them and then finally I'd
like to acknowledge Beckman Coulter life
sciences for their support
Chad Schwartz and Randy Wagner
and for for their help are they really
facilitated a lot of work so with that
done I think we have a couple more
minutes for some questions thank you
thank you very much Peter for the
presentation very well-spoken succinct
material and looking forward to the next
in the series that we have planned with
you this year we do have time for one or
two questions and of course we will take
all of the questions that we have
received in the chat window and provide
them to Peter for his review to provide
written answers and send that out to all
of the attendees of the webinar so we
will try to answer your question one way
or another
Peter that there were some themes here
and one question especially well since
I'm moderating today I get to decide I'm
going to ask you this one because it's
an area of excitement for me and
overlaps with our other webinar series
and that is what would you be able to
potentially separate extracellular
vesicles that are sub micron in size
using this technique oh thanks for that
question
yeah you know that's interesting you
know what we're doing right now is
essentially throwing that stuff away in
our in our small particle cleanups work
but there I believe there has been
utility of parolee traders in the past
for Piko plankton and and and that is
getting into about the size range of the
of these micro particles so I I would
expect that this could be done we
haven't been looking at that but it's
it's a very hot topic right now in in in
a water fields and in you know we will
probably be be looking at this on our
systems with the current commercial
available commercially available
chambers you know possibly we may
discover that there may be a need for
some modification of the chamber or
something but or or modifications to the
loading buffers or whatever or some kind
of changing that can can be had with
with the current equipment but I think
there's a very strong possibility that
we that this should be possible okay
thank you very much for that information
another question one came in from Europe
what is the precision of the instrument
in terms of cell size is it able to for
example differentiate between three and
four micron cells I've seen reported
about 1/2 of micron in using the
sanderson chamber you know the there are
ways of improving resolution if you if
you have a known size range like what
would ask the 4 to 5 micron size range
it's possible to get higher resolution
of separation by speeding up the by
speeding up the RPMs by keeping it and
currently we do to 2500 rpm if you go to
a higher range you can take a array you
can take a size the size range and kind
of expand it and get and get some
further fractionation we haven't we
haven't explored that but I think right
now what I realised seemed to be level
being reported was about a half a micron
I questions about a number of cells and
maximum so maybe I'll ask in two ways
are there any minimum number of cells to
separate starting points percent
recoveries of the technique and then
another question is there a maximum
concentration of cells while injecting
which seems to be a bit similar yeah a
couple of couple points there is a
effectiveness of loading and it seems
too far off on the small side
so if loading if we're loading numbers
with numbers of 10 to the fifth or 10 or
so start to become difficult there's a
lot of you seem to start losing a lot
more material when you get back small
now that is with the current chamber
setups and so forth the on the high side
the material does get diluted I don't
know if I can pull back to the delivery
system I can here everybody can see that
the material is introduced into that
unit and it's it's the fact that we do
them it's the same number of cells that
end up in the in the sector fuge so you
know like a like any other type of
gradient of this probably an overloading
condition where you've got just too much
material in there there are probably
ways around this I have seen some
modifications to the delivery system
when you process a lot more material
there aren't there are ways to skin the
cat for sure the the information in the
manual for the existing chain
I'm sorry will will illustrate get into
it quickly understand it sorry will
illustrate what the kind of what the
ranges are I'll compare this what the
Rangers are for these employees current
chambers but you know this there's a lot
of latitude but you're not seeing
numbers like 10 to 50 on there because
you start losing material when you can
walk on the small side
okay we actually have quite a few
questions coming in so I'm going to ask
one more question and then close out the
webinar because we are already just a
bit over the time that we allotted one
last question for today live is there a
way to separate cells of different sizes
but the same mass and we had a similar
question that was the converse what a
what this is based upon is it density
mass for example if you have something
that is the same size but different
masses can you separate that with
elutriation so you know some there is
some drag about Tara because you do have
a fluid flow the it's really the
sedimentation velocity that that's kind
of the prime component of of the
technique you you can exploit some of
these differences by changing by
changing the buffer and actually putting
gradient type buffers into the system
these things are can certainly be played
you know a lot of this is just
determined by by by the experiment so
you know I would I would I would not
dismiss any of these possibilities I
would I would
certainly try them out especially if you
can do it it controlled right professor
Lopez thank you very much for today's
seminar and to all the attendees thank
you for joining us today
the webinar will be made available
on-demand please check back to our web
our website frequently for future
webinar topics and thank you again for
joining us today